today my guest is Nelson Dellis who is
and you're gonna provide more details
but you are an experienced or put it
this way an expert on memory yes and you
have also expressed an interest in in
art you've talked about the importance
of language learning and you yourself
learnt Dutch so I want to explore memory
and language learning because that's a
great interest to the people who follow
me did you begin perhaps by introducing
yourself yeah so thank you for having me
on your channel here yeah so I actually
grew up speaking French mostly with my
parents there from Belgium French area
and so language has always been kind of
important in my life obviously perfect
English it's my main language now and
has been for the last probably 30 ish
years but my mother's side was Dutch and
Flemish and I always want to kind of
explore that but I never gave myself the
chance that's one side of the story my
memory journey started about ten years
ago when my grandmother passed away from
Alzheimer's and it kind of inspired me
to start investigating what it meant to
have a healthy brain and if there were
techniques or any strategies I could
learn to train my own memory to be
better lo and behold I found some and
worked on it a lot and led me to win the
US memory championship a number of times
and kind of make memory something that I
now teach people very interesting when
you mentioned memory I remember once I
was in Slovakia okay I was holidaying
there with my son and his family they
live in London England and we had a
member of link who lived nearby we were
in the mountains but we met in a smaller
town and he had some trick that I can't
remember but he wrote a bunch of numbers
out on a piece of paper and then did
something and he could he would remember
which number was where on the piece of
paper yeah we were just amazed at how he
did this but in something that you just
couldn't do if you didn't know
if you didn't have some tricks a good
idea yeah yeah yeah and that's that's
off it I mean we don't do that trick in
particular but I know how we would have
done that and then these competitions
were tested on how many numbers you can
remember how many playing cards poetry
lists of words things like that so it is
very it looks like a feat of memory like
something like this is out of this world
but it's trainable so is there a simple
explanation sort of at a summary of sort
of these techniques what is it about
these techniques how do they work how
does a person trained to be able to do
these things
sure so I'd like to break it down into
kind of three basic steps and this is
how I approach basically anything that I
memorize most things that I memorize
first thing is to think of a picture so
whatever I'm trying to memorize I try to
kind of strip away the foreignness of it
and make it familiar to me because most
things that you're learning it's
something you've never seen before
that's why it's difficult to learn it
was easy to learn or something familiar
probably would stick better right so my
goal is to kind of trick my brain into
thinking it's something familiar so that
usually is in the form of some type of
Association or some kind of system that
I've developed to translate complicated
information into reliable memorable
pictures we remember pictures better so
that's the first step the second step is
how do I organize those pictures or
photographs in my mind and the most
commonly used technique in memory
competitions at least is something
called a memory palace where you imagine
a physical space in your mind and you
place those pictures along a route
through them and the idea is that we
remember places very well as well so why
not use them to remember the order of
things of those pictures that's not the
only way to do it but basically it's
some kind of strategy to store
information mm-hmm second step how to
store that information in a easily
retrievable way and then the final step
is review so if you want to keep things
for a long time for long term you have
to review it now that doesn't ever sound
very fun but what's nice about
1 & 2 is that the review can actually
become a little more enjoyable if you
treat it that way and then it's not so
tedious as studying a book you know you
can't explore these crazy images in your
mind so then how were you able to apply
this to learning Dutch now you said you
your parents were from the Dutch or
Flemish speaking part of Belgium so you
would have heard Dutch presumably as a
child yeah I don't really what AG came
to the United States yeah but you would
have had some exposure to Dutch yeah so
let me let me talk about that so
actually my dad speaks French that's it
okay French Belgian he knows absolutely
nothing about Dutch Flemish and he
actually grew up mostly in France so I
okay he's panco fun okay and then my
mother is completely Dutch she's right
huh that she has that accent but she
speaks French and that's what they spoke
together when I grow up so he always
heard French around the house right and
slowly spoke French we actually lived
there for a while too I Belgian the
Flemish you know I really only hear that
when she was on the phone maybe with her
sister and but you're right I died of
course I heard it
there's certainly little phrases she
says that I can repeat but you know I
never knew the meaning I just said them
but it for a long time it just felt like
a very foreign kind of hard language to
grasp so yeah so that was the start of
my exposure to the language and that's
been I'm 36 so I 34 35 I started
thinking about maybe trying to learn it
and in a way to get closer to my mother
right to be able to speak with her to
kind of her have that side of my family
mm-hmm now how did I tie that to my
memory techniques that was kind of the
goal right to figure that out or to
attempt it and see how it went one of
the things I get told or asked of all
the time is you must be amazing with
languages because your memory or do you
ever use your memory to learn a language
right and that question is kind of
insane right because I don't think
anyone learns a language with memory
alone right I'm totally aware that
and I was aware that but I did believe
that my memory would serve as a great
help in kind of advancing me in certain
areas so I began kind of exploring what
that would look like and I thought to
myself well because I can memorize words
pretty fast why not try and tackle a
large set of vocabulary to start with so
I have some kind of base to build on
right and then from there I can maybe
explore other kind of avenues of
traditional and language learning or
different methods that aren't so memory
based but at least I would have a
foundation and that's that's kind of the
process started and so what did you find
did you find that the the memory
techniques were helpful yeah so one of
the things I think that's been tough for
me and probably a lot of people who want
to learn a language is just getting
started
right for years I've been saying oh I
can learn a language right I have to
apply my memory and put the work in but
that's easier said than done
and you know you buy the books you you
know you you pay for the courses or
whatever you have a tutor lined up and
then you know one thing leads to another
you're not doing any of the work right
right you got to do the work and I think
a big part of my problem is is I needed
something simple that would get me
started that would kind of play on what
I enjoy which is the memory side of
thing maybe not everybody likes that but
for me I enjoy sitting down and coming
up with these fun associations a lot of
them really quickly and so I use this
app called drops that presents a lot of
vocabulary in a fun kind of
aesthetically pleasing way and it's very
minimal at first right you don't have to
kind of commit a lot to start and that's
what I needed and I found myself kind of
always going back to it learning a bunch
of words every day
and my goal was to learn about 2,000
words in 90 days mm-hmm
and I use the app to do that just
because it helped kind of organize the
different kind of categories and help me
review as well so yeah after the 90 days
I believe I was success
successful you know I had my mother test
me and you know quiz me on words and and
I was able to nail you know ninety
percent of them I with some might need a
little review but I'd get them and and
then from then obviously I wasn't fluent
at all but I would say that I felt more
confident at that point and I had built
so much you know kind of consistency at
that point that it was very easy to kind
of move on to the next step and really
work on the language and write yeah it's
interesting like obviously a major
factor in language learning is as I
always say it's the motivation of the
learner and the amount of time that
they're willing to put in yeah there is
a third element that I sometimes talk
about which is the ability to notice but
that develops naturally if you spend a
lot of time with the language you start
to notice more and more things in the
language so it's not you're not
deliberately I'm going to learn how to
notice but if you are motivated and if
you spend the time things that at first
you don't notice in the language they
start to become clearer certain words
certain structures and what I have found
is that so first of all to get started
in the language as I have said I go
through these mini stories that we have
at link right and based on and in
particular the last few languages that
I've started to learn I've relied
entirely on the mini stories that was
for Greek for Persian for Arabic and for
Turkish and typically after your three
months just through repetitive listening
to the mini stories I will achieve three
to four thousand words now the thing is
in in languages the very high frequency
words of course they reappear very
frequently because their high frequency
well if the frequency drops off very
quickly so if you shall learn a thousand
words that to me is like doable okay
yeah through a memory system through the
many stories I when I was learning a
thousand characters of Chinese I had a
very primitive spaced repetition system
this is fifty years ago that I did you
know so so a finite number
of things words whatever it might be I
think it's very definitely amenable to
some clever memory system so the the the
issues I have with that as a sort of an
approach to language learning issues are
that if you like doing that that's great
if people like studying grammar that's
great so if that motivates you that's
great
but if it doesn't motivate you then the
one big factor of motivation is now- not
my do not everybody likes to listen to
the stories 20 30 40 times the way I do
so everyone has to find that thing that
motivates them that's enjoyable or
challenging so that they continue doing
it so they put in the time and so you
can get to that first few thousand words
with either memory system are many
stories or whatever but now you have to
in order to be really fluent and they
talk about the European framework of
reference or call it advanced
intermediate you know be tuned
comfortable you speak with mistakes but
you can sit in there and talk about a
wide variety of subjects maybe even
follow a movie and to get to that level
you need a awful lot of words it's not a
thousand and it's probably closer to
twenty or thirty thousand based on my
experience and the frequency drops off
so quickly that once you've got the
first files under 2,000 words thereafter
you're chasing words that might appear
in a book five times sure and yet you
need them because those are key to to
being able to participate because the
native speaker has 40,000 words 50,000
words and he's gonna or she is going to
use these in conversation you don't have
to be able to use them but you have to
be able to understand what they're
saying
so the question I have is so a memory
system can be a really good for people
who are good at it I think that could
like I I'm struggling with my Persian I
see the same word over and over again I
can never remember what it means yeah if
I had a memory system perhaps I could
nail those few words but it's still only
that very first part of the journey so
how do you apply the memory system to
30,000 words yeah yeah
no that's a great great point you bring
up and by no means am I saying that the
only way to learn a language or the best
way is the way I approached it I was
definitely pulling on the way that's
made sense to me and it was definitely a
motivational thing for me
right I enjoyed that one thing I will
say though is you know I don't think you
necessarily have to be good at memory
techniques to enjoy them I always kind
of pitch what I teach
as you know memory techniques can be
enjoyable to everyone I think it's a
really enjoyable experience it's fun to
dick ting if you know how to do it right
with a bit of instruction and learning
how to do it so I believe everybody can
kind of get to that point but you're
right maybe the idea of memorizing 1,000
words or 2,000 words in a few days or a
month or whatever you aim for it just no
matter how interesting memory techniques
is maybe that doesn't sound like your
cup of tea but no I think it's no I
think the difficulty is so there's two
one is that is you're gonna work in the
long run and even if it doesn't if it
gets you started in the language it's a
good thing I'm not exactly saying that
it's a great thing to do the the
question the problem I've always had
with memory techniques or minim onyx or
whatever column is it whatever you're
doing whether you're on drops or link or
whatever you have to believe in the
system yeah so you have to invest the
time you gotta say it's worth my while
to develop these language learning
techniques I think it's good I want to
spend time because okay when I'm
listening to a story at least the
language is flowing into my brain I
enjoy it I'm listening there's the music
of the language and I'm happy doing that
and I know her experience that it works
so alright I know that's good but
there's a more efficient way and that's
to invest this time in nelson's learning
techniques so I have to believe because
if I don't believe it I'm not gonna
really put the effort into it so it's
like I'm not gonna invest upfront in
something that Nelson says gonna help me
so how do you overcome that sort of
skepticism you know I've seen these
references to the sort of Roman house or
Roman Palace or whatever it was you know
and I've always just my nature I said
yeah I'm just reluctant to invest the
time in that and and so how do you
overcome that reluctance or or in fact
do you find much reluctance are people
very happy to to jump in there and learn
these techniques I think it's kind of a
mixed bag and and maybe some of it comes
from not quite understanding like I know
when you're talking about this room and
room method that sounds like a lot of
extra work a big investment to kind of
set this up but really my approach was I
actually didn't use any memory palaces
at all our Roman rooms which they
require a lot of setup because my idea
is you know I want to be able to speak
this I access the information pretty
quickly I don't want to have to sit
there look up specific words and their
meanings I want to be as easy to come
out as possible and so a lot of the
stuff I did was essentially just pure
Association so in connecting instead of
connecting it to a memory cause
connecting each word to each other each
image to each other let's say so a lot
of the process was very quick you know I
see a word in target language it's no
demeaning and then kind of come up with
pictures for both and then anchor them
together mm-hmm so whether I see one or
the other I can hopefully remember the
the connection it made in terms of kind
of convincing someone that this is the
method to do I'm gonna go back to the
fact that it it's fun and addicting to
know or recognize words right right yes
like there's a good feeling when you say
I know this word and I know all these
words all the colors all the the monks
all these verbs whatever right and I
think that's that builds on itself and I
think there's a lot of importance to
getting started with something that kind
of fuels you going forward right and
makes you consistent in this language
learning process again I don't know if I
would just say hey everybody out there
has to learn don't know words whatever
everyone is interested in in techniques
that are gonna help them learn more
quickly
yeah and that's that's I think what
feels good it is maybe it's a false
quite sense of being you know you're
approaching fluency but there is
progress being made right you know 1,000
words you know a thousand words exactly
now just to sort of explore a couple of
different situations when I was learning
Chinese characters and I used as I say a
space repetition system but a manual one
that I had and so you learning a
thousand characters I mean they're
almost learning items on their own
because these characters are so
unrelated to anything so you're just
learning objects okay so when I learn
words sorry from learning words in a
related language which is the case with
say Dutch because it's so many words are
identifiable from English or even from
French and French to English and there's
lots of stuff there that you can or
German that you can identify so you've
got the word which you connect to the
word in the language you know you may
even get a freebie because it looks like
the word in the language you know that's
slightly different meaning so there's an
association you start to see forms of
that word so now you've got additional
associations so there are a lot of
associations that that are there yeah
and and I guess I rely on those
associations when I'm learning
associations with words that are often
used with that word so you you know that
that's used together with something else
but the interesting thing is things like
numbers and colors which I know I mean
if I see a word for red I know the color
red or blue or green I find those very
difficult to remember if I come across a
word in Persian for situation condition
any of those words which have more
meaning I mean I remember those are easy
O's grab me those have resonance as I
can never is that green is it red is it
white I can't remember now maybe there
are there are certain kinds of
vocabulary that we should have a
deliberate sort of memory technique
approach to because they're
intrinsically like I find that numbers
and colors are so hardwired in our own
language that they're difficult to learn
in another language all right that's my
theory but maybe that's not but I do I
always find them difficult when people
start well today you know a chapter
three we're gonna do the parts of the
body or we're gonna do you know the
names of all our relatives or the colors
I find those things impossible to
remember but verbs you know go come need
give take those things are easy to
remember free for they show up very
often and they're easier to remember
just by being in some kind of meaningful
context like a little story whereas
things like colors they kind of stand on
their own in a way yeah they're these
kind of islands I actually I agree with
you because I think the reason is
because a lot of verbs for example and
these kind of more abstract terms we
have to almost create the way we know
what they mean in our part or in our
native language is it's hard to say okay
that is the situation there's that thing
right there right you have to kind of
describe a situation you know can be
here's an example or right we have you
know analogies or metaphors or something
and I think all of that is tagged with
emotion and right and the feelings that
go with it
which is so much more memorable than
saying green blue yeah and that's
exactly why those are more complicated
so I don't know if that we were you were
leading with that question but yeah so
I'm saying so the whole issue is you
know as you're investing time in your
language learning how much time you
can't spend all your time
let's take extreme case mmm learning
words on their own because then you're
missing you're not listening you're not
reading you're not training the brain in
the patterns and the structures and the
sound and the feel of the new language
however it's inefficient to the extent
that you keep on forgetting the same
words so if you were able to zoom in on
some vocabulary and and really grab a
hold of those words that that would help
you so the question is how much time you
spend on sort of more conventional
listening and reading
imbibing the language getting used to
language activities how much time should
you spend on the more targeted you know
memory technique to grab words and hold
them and have
and and and I guess a related question
is you've used your memory technique to
learn a word if you don't see that word
in any kind of a context for certain
amount of time aren't you going to lose
it anyway
yeah no you're perfectly right and
here's the here's the follow up to my my
my challenge I made for myself for 90
days to learn those words is after that
you know I didn't do any more of that it
was all what you're talking about right
I worked with the tutor all right and we
met and to speak to we had a few books
that we were kind of doing exercises
with I was studying you know my grammar
and using examples listening to movies
cartoons all those things trying to be
as facing this language as possible
right and um to be honest in terms of
memory techniques where I sat down and
say like oh I need a memory technique
for that I'd say it went from 100% in
those first you know a few weeks in 20
words to maybe 5 to 10% right so I
definitely I think it has its place for
certain things and even the five 10%
that I'm talking about I would maybe use
if there was like some conjugation of a
verb that just wouldn't stick right I
wouldn't force all these verbs in my
head with memory techniques I actually
would just use them for certain things
that I kept bumping into you know or
things I kept saying wrong or you know
where pronounce things to try to
remember some of those things because
yeah I totally recognize and I totally
agree with you that I think you have to
be you know if you're these words need
to be used
you need to hear them and to see them
and to kill them if not they're just
gonna be you know eventually they're
gonna they're gonna fade away the
certainly the use of memory techniques
is big in language learning you have
space repetition systems for example
which is a different approach it's not
Association it's more some kind of
algorithm of overt I know how frequently
you need to see them and and I think
these things are very useful especially
at the beginning and also as you
mentioned you know declensions
conjugations which are so difficult
but again you don't need to
unnecessarily theoretically know what
the conjugation is like I got mentioned
the example in English most people know
that the third-person singular and the
present takes present tense takes s he
goes he comes
you know however people regularly say he
come he go so it's not that they don't
remember or that they don't know but
they can't produce it in the middle of a
conversation
so again knowing it however if you know
it you're more likely perhaps eventually
to be able to produce it you know if you
talk about it you know the perb endings
in French or in I don't know much but
you know declensions or whatever so yeah
I think there's a real place for memory
techniques whether it be you know the
kind of memory techniques that you are
an expert in or spaced repetition
systems but it should be in a very sort
of deliberate well-defined area that it
shouldn't take away too much time from
and I think it's particularly important
in the beginning to get a toehold
because everything is just noise like
all these words that mean nothing yeah
so then you get yourself a toehold but
then we don't want to spend too much
time on that at the expense of more
general exposure to the language and
it's also depends on what people like to
do of course yeah exactly no I you know
I think you're making some great points
that I agree with a lot of them I mean
yeah okay well listen this is very
interesting and and it's gonna be
interesting so if people want to learn
more about your memory techniques yeah
what can what should they do well I
think the the best place to start might
be to go to my youtube channel I have a
bunch of videos some wrong on what I've
been doing with Dutch and then some are
just general memory techniques you
search my name there Nelson Dellis and
then my website people can go there it's
Nelson Dellis comm and ask me questions
send me it somewhere I know okay well
this is very interesting and I'm sure
many of the people who follow my channel
here will be very very interested hey
quick question for you so on link it I
always pronounce that Ling
q but I guess finally we get both we're
happy as long as people join me I happy
yeah sure I played around with it I find
it fascinating I want to maybe try it
for a different language goal of mine
but they have Swahili or no no no okay
we have I think C well in order to
launch a new language we said we want a
minimum of X amount of content yeah
because if there's no content there and
someone joins for the purpose of
learning Swahili and there's one story
there then we're misleading them so we
have to have a minimum of a certain
amount of content and we have had these
mini stories because it's easy enough we
say okay we get Swahili someone has to
an occasion he will subsidize it
translate them into Swahili record them
in Swahili audio with text if we have 60
stories in Swahili we will launch
Swahili I gather I think someone is
working on Swahili so it may be that we
will get Swahili but at the present time
we don't have psyche we have Dutch yeah
no I played around with it yeah
interfere across kind of methods but I
was by the whole approach I think it's
no we're continuously adding languages
and we're working on improving it and
it's it's an ongoing project it's like a
permanent sure yeah yeah when do you
when you finish yeah never ever okay
well I think that's me interesting thank
you very much and maybe look forward to
talking again and I will let you know if
we get when we get Swahili lights okay
perfect thank you okay
thank you pleasure thank you so much
thank you bye
[Music]